يمكن للعلماء في مختبر فلوريدا أن يشعروا
بشيء كبير داخل هذا الثعبان البورمي الميت الذي يبلغ ارتفاعه 18 قدمًا ،
لذا قاموا بقطعه وفتح
تشريح يسمى أو
اعتقدت أنه كان مقرفًا جدًا أيضًا وأنا
معتاد على عمليات التشريح والأشياء التي كانت روزي
مور واحدة من  العلماء
يحققون في النظام الغذائي للثعبان وينظرون إلى
ما كان موجودًا في قائمة بايثون
ميتًا بطول خمسة أقدام ولكن لا يزال التمساح سليمًا إلى حد ما
هل كانت رائحته كريهة يا
إلهي كنا نأخذ فترات راحة كنا
نركض في الخارج نحاول الحصول على بعض
الهواء النقي وكأنني لم أشم أي شيء أبدًا  من
هذا القبيل ، تهنئة كليمنتر مازحًا لأن ثعبانك
حامل
مع تمساح ،
تشجع فلوريدا الناس على قتل
الثعابين البورمية لأنهم يأكلون العديد
من الأنواع الأخرى ويتكاثرون بسرعة ، وهو ما
يطلق عليه في الواقع غزو الثعبان ،
نعم يشار إليه عادة باسم
غزو الثعبان التمساح في الداخل  انتشر
مقطع فيديو الثعبان على صفحة روزي على الإنستغرام
، وربما لم تكن صور
العلماء الذين كانوا يشبهون فتاة بوند في
البيكيني '  تؤذي نسبة المشاهدة ، إنها عارضة أزياء
بدوام جزئي وتحب
فكرة تغيير صورة
العالمات الإناث دائمًا ما يتم تصوير النساء في العلوم على أنهن
نوعًا ما يتم تصويرهن على أنهن
خجولات نردي وليس هذه المرأة في العلوم التي
تغوص في وظيفتها بشغف
التمساح والثعبان  علمت روزي
كلمة جديدة اقترحها شخص ما كان يجب أن
تطبخ للتو الأمر برمته كان من الممكن أن
يكون نوعًا من نسخة Cajun المخيفة
من الديك الرومي المحشو
بالبط والدجاج ، لذلك ربما
نسمي هذا فطيرة gatorthon ليس
لأنه يجعل أي شخص جائعًا
سينما سي إن إن نيويورك